[موسيقى]
مره عام ولم تتحقق العداله بعد لكن حقا
ورائهم مطالب لن يسقط لا بالتقادمي ولا
بالتخاذل ولا بالتطبيع ولا بالتنميه وسيظل
احرار العالم يطالبون بالعداله لشيرين الى
ان ينال المجرمون جزاءهم اولئك الذين
يجابهون الكلمه بالرصاص والحقيقه بالوهم
والشجاعه بالظلم لن يقتلوا الكلمه لم
يقمصوا الحقيقه ولن ينالوا من الشجاعه
الصحافه ليست جريمه وشيرين رغم الغياب لم
يزل حضورها طاغيا حاضره بين زملائها وهم
يرصدون عمليات الدهم والاقتحام
الاسرائيليه المتكرره في كافه المدن
الفلسطينيه خاصه جنين حيث استشهدت قبل عام
حظيره بين ابناء شعبها الذي انحازت له دون
تفريط في مهنيتها امام احتلال لم يكتفي
بسرقه ارضه
عاقبته جماعيا على مقاومته لكنه يحاول
ايضا اختراق نسيجه المجتمع واثاره الشكوك
في صفوفه عبر وحدات سريه خاصه عناصرها
يشبهون العرب يتحدثون بلسانهم ويندسون
بينهم لجمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه او
للانقضاض على الفلسطينيين عنفا واعتداء
واعتقالا وحتى قتلا وهم لا يتلقون الاوامر
الا من اعلى الهرم في سلطه الاحتلال احدى
هذه الوحدات وهي ضفدفان لم تستبعد تقارير
اسرائيليه مسؤوليه احد افرادها عن استهداف
الشرير انها وحدات مستعربين التي يتسلل
عناصرها الى المدن الفلسطينيه يتنكرون
احيانا في ملابس الرجال دين وسيدات محجبات
او في هيئه صحفيين استهداف المقاومين في
نابلس وفي جنين وحده التحقيق المعماري في
مؤسسه الحق بالتعاون مع فرنسك خصت برنامجا
للقصه بقيه بنتائج تحقيق وصور ومعلومات
ترصد مجريات هجومين على المدينتين في
يناير وفبراير الماضي اسفر عن استشهاد
اكثر من عشرين فلسطينيا واصابه عشرات
في قصتنا الليله نرصد طريقه تجنيد وعمل
هذه الوحدات عبر مقابلات خاصه مع احد
عناصرها السابقين ومع الرئيس الاسبق لجهاز
المخابرات الاسرائيلي الموساد يتوم ومع
شهود عيان فلسطين كما حاولنا رصد الابعاد
القانونيه لعمل هذه الوحدات وتاثيرها على
المجتمع الفلسطيني اما بقيه القصه
فنستكملها مع الدكتور سعيد بشارات الباحث
في شؤون الاسرائيليه والدكتور بروسفين
الخبير القانوني ونائب مساعدي وزير العدل
الامريكي السابق والمصور الصحفي عمير
ستيتيه ونسالهم عن المسار التاريخي لتشكيل
وحدات المستعربين الاسرائيليه وتطور عملها
والى اي مدى وصلت انتهاكاتها بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني وعن امكانيه تقديم عناصرها
والمسؤولين الى العداله في ضوء ما يتكشف
من معلومات عن اعمالها التي تعد انتهاكات
للقوانين الدوليه لكن لنشاهد القصه اولا
وبعدها الحوار
هنا في المدن والقرى الفلسطينيه نتعقب
استراتيجيات عمل احدى اشد وحدات القوات
الاسرائيليه الخاصه سريه والتي تعرف
بالمستعربين
وحده يتخفى افرادها وراء اقنعه عده
وينشطون في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وقطاع
غزه متنكرين في هيئه فلسطينيين
وتعد اداه محوريه في حرب المدن التي تشنها
اسرائيل
يقوم المستعرض بما لا يستطيع الجندي
النظامي القيام به والذي لا يستطيع حتى
الوصول الى هذه الاماكن
[موسيقى]
تعتبرهم اسرائيل قوات خاصه مختصه بمكافحه
الارهاب اما الفلسطينيون فيعدونهم فرقه
موت عنيفه
[موسيقى]
انهم في غايه الاهميه هم جوهر قواتنا
العامله يهوذا والسامره الذين يعرفون كيف
يظهرون في وسط جنين ونابلس
ويبدون مثل العرب
ومن ثم ينفذون الهجمات
تتمثل مهمه المستعربين في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه ومطارده الفلسطينيين
المطلوبين بطرق مختلفه
يتنكرونك فلسطينيين محليين يصعب تمييزهم
وفي لحظه معينه يشرعون في اعتقال
الفلسطينيين بقوه السلاح
المستعرب المتخفي يتحدث العربيه بطلاقه
ويفهم الثقافه يمشي في احد شوارع غزه دون
ان يثير اي شيء
[موسيقى]
عضو سابق في القوات الخاصه الاسرائيليه
خدمك مستعرب وفي قوات الدعم خاصه برنامجا
للقصه بقيه بشهاده حصريه تكشف خفايا عمل
وحده المستعربين في فلسطين
[موسيقى]
يجب ان يرتدوك العرب
ويتحدث اللغه بطلاقه مع اتقان اللهجه
[موسيقى]
وعليهم ان يفهموا الثقافه والعقليه وعليهم
ان يفهموا القران
[موسيقى]
عمليا يجب ان تبدا العمليه العسكريه
والقمع في حرب المدن من الداخل الى الخارج
وليس من الخارج الى الداخل بالطبع كل
مدينه فلسطينيه محاطه بمستوطنات فيها جنود
وبقواعد عسكريه وبالجدار وبنقاط تفتيش لكن
الجنود ليسوا في الداخل وعندما يتحركون
بالزي العسكري من الخارج الى الداخل
فسيكونون مكشوفين وسيتاهب الجميع
لمواجهتهم
تختار قوات الامن الاسرائيليه والجيش
الاسرائيلي عناصر وحده المستعربين بعنايه
ويخضعون لتدريب طويل ومكثف على حرب المدن
من خلال تعقبنا لعمل هذه الوحده خلصنا الى
ان عمليه مطارده الفلسطينيين المطلوبين
تمر بمراحل ثلاث
الاولى جمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه او
المعلومات الساخنه كما يسمونها وتتولى ذلك
وحده سريه ذات خبره ينزرع عناصرها بين
الفلسطينيين لمده زمنيه طويله قد تصل
لاعوام المرحله الثانيه تتمثل بارسال
عناصر القوات الخاصه الكوماندوز للتسلل
وتنفيذ المهمه وغالبا ما تتمثل بالاختطاف
او الاعدام اما المرحله الاخيره فتتمثل
بالتدخل العسكري للقوات النظاميه
والمدرعات
المستعربون المتخفون في العمليه او في
الاتصالات اللاسلكيه يدعون الملونين
اما الجنود الذين يرتدون الزي الرسميه
فيدعاون الخضر
الملون هم العناصر المتخفيه التي تشرع في
الهجوم والخضر هم قوه الدعم
يتم تدريب المتخفين على التركيز في مهمتهم
ويحصلون على الدعم من القناصين وهم من
الخضر او مختصي زرع المتفجرات لنسف منازل
الفلسطينيين
توصل تحقيقنا الى ان المداهمات في انحاء
الضفه الغربيه تقودها بشكل اساسي وحدات
سريه
تتبعنا مداهمات مختلفه لكن ارتكز تحقيقنا
على تقصف مداهمه البلده القديمه في نابلس
التي وقعت في فبراير 2023 واسفرت عن
استشهاد احد عشر فلسطينيا واصابه 100
جمعنا اكثر من عشر شهادات وراجعنا اكثر من
30 مقطع فيديو ولقطه كاميرات مراقبه
وحددنا الموقع الجغرافي للحوادث الكبرى
وتتبعنا ميدانيا الادله البصريه في مختلف
انحاء المدينه القديمه في حوالي الساعه
التاسعه والنصف صباحا تسلل سبعه عناصر من
المستعربين الى المدينه القديمه متنكرين
في هيئه شخصيات دينيه وكان بعضهم يرتدي
جيا نسائيا
اخبرنا شهود عيان ان المستهربين توجهوا
نحو المنزل المستهدف الذي كان يحتمي فيه
ثلاثه رجال مطلوبين من بينهم احد مقاوم
كتيبه عرين الاسود
طوق المنزل واستخدموا ثلاثه منازل اخرى
كنقاط اطلاق نار قبل ان يتدخل الجيش لعجل
المدينه القديمه عن باقي مناطق نابلس
ام احمد مالكه مطعم يقع اسفل المنزل
مباشره تروي لنا تفاصيل ساعات الاقتحام
التي عايشتها بنفسها
في منهن
اشي لابس نساء اواعي نسائيه
يعني دشاديش زي الدعوه الاسلاميه للرجال
الدعوه والنساء لابسين هو نساء اسوا من
السيء طبعا
نفسيتنا دمار
مجازر بره تحسي ان صوت الطخو الانفجارات
واحنا نفسيتنا جوا عمل لدرجه انه كل ما
طلع انفجار
الازاز عنا يتطاير علينا تراب حجار من
الحيطان
العفش يقلب نقوط الانفجار
نفسيتنا زي العمى في عندي كان ولد كمان
عمر 16 سنه
ما كنتش اعرف وينه يعني اتصل على علامه ما
يردش علي ما يردوش هاد برضه وترني اكثر
فوق ما انا متوتره من الاصوات ومن
اسمعه واحنا محشورين جوا
الاربع ساعات واحنا جوا مسكر علينا الباب
اعطيته هذا الركاب استخدمت القوات الخاصه
انس 16 عاما كدرع بشري
كنت طالعه زبطتن المي
فجاه خلصت هذا شغله بدي انزل لسه اول درشه
تفاجات بالقوات الخاصه
انا هلا وجهي خلاني لتحت فحط الباروده هون
قبل ما نزل من هون ونزلني لتحت اخذني زي
درع بشري او درع له
هلا لما انا اخذني درع بشري تحط البارود
اللي على كتفي وطخ كم من طلقه فيها
اه من شان ياخذ هذه لعبه
او نزل نزل تخبى هون لتحت بحط نعناع
جديد كان من اول ثلاث جيبات خاشه تال جيش
فايت مقتحم بس اما قوات خاصه والسعر بين
اول اشي الفوتو يا ابن المنطه وقناصه اول
مره علينا انا بس ما عدت اقتحامات بالليل
بتصير اخذوا النقاط اقتحموا حاصروا بس زي
هاي المره بالنهار لا الترتيب بصير
دخلوا قوات اول شيء قوات مستعربه
بحاصل المنطقه بعدين بتشعل جيش لهم حمايه
بيعملوا زي طوق امني عليها على المنطقه
المحاصره
بيعطلوا القناصات الصح المنازل
بصير يتاكل النار على كل شيء يتحرك يعني
[موسيقى]
حاولنا ان نبذل قصار جهدنا واحيانا اتخذنا
اجراءات عرضت جنودنا للخطر من اجل تجنب
الحاق الاذى باشخاص غير متورطين اي من
نسميهم الابرياء
لكن لسوء الحظ في المنطقه التي تدور فيها
الحرب
ورغم انها منطقه محدوده كانت هناك بعض
الحالات التي قتل او جرح فيها اشخاص
ابرياء
تواصلنا مع الجيش الاسرائيلي للتعليق على
ما وصف بجرائم وحده المستهربين والقوات
الخاصه في نابلس وجنين وعاقب محاولات عده
اجابنا الجيش ان ملابسات حادثه نابلس التي
اوقعت قتلى فلسطينيين وفق ما جاء في رده
لا تزال قيد الدراسه كما نفع استخدام
المدنيين كدروع بشريه
المختلف في الواقع الاسرائيلي هو حقيقه ان
هذه الوحدات عاده ما تعمل في الاراضي
المحتله في الضفه الغربيه
وهي مناطق خاضعه للاحتلال العسكري وقانون
حقوق الانسان وقوانين النزاع المسلح في
الوقت نفسه ما يخلق وضعا فريدا ومعقدا
للغايه
لا شك ان ما يجعل منها حاله فريده من
نوعها يقع في صميم القانون الدولي
الانساني وقوانين النزاع المسلح
اذ بموجب هذه القوانين هناك قيود محدده
على ما يسمح لك وما لا يسمح لك بفعله
اثناء ارتداء الملابس المدنيه
يقتصر العمل بالزي المدني على العمليات
الاستخباراتيه تحديدا ما يعني انه لا يسمح
لك بمهاجمه اي شخص اثناء ارتداء الزي
المدني
حيث قد يؤدي قيامك بذلك الى اتهامك بقتل
او اصابه شخص خيانه او غدرا وهذا يمكن ان
يرقى الى جريمه حرب
خلال سعينا للكشف عن الانماط المستخدمه في
مداهمتنابلس وجنين في شهرين وفبراير 2023
توصلنا الى تحقيق اجرتهم مؤسسه الحق
وفرنسك ننفرد بنشر نتائجها في برنامج
للقصه بقيه يحدثنا الباحث من مؤسسه الحق
الذي فضل عدم الكشف عن هويته
تمكنا من تحديد النمط المتمثلي بنشر
القوات المسلحه الاسرائيليه لسيارات ذات
مظهر مدني
او جنود يرتدون ملابس مدنيه
كما وجدنا ان الجيش كان يداهم منازل
المدنيين
ثم يستخدم منازلهم كقواعد عسكريه للتمركز
قناص
كما ترون هنا لو ان مسار تحرك القوات
الاسرائيليه باللون الوردي او الاحمر
وترون هنا ان القوات الاسرائيليه تداهمت
منازل مختلفه في انحاء المخيم وصل مجموعها
الى حوالي خمسه منازل مشكل حصارا حول
المنزل اي انهم قاموا بتطويق المنزل من
جميع الجهات
اما عن الاكتشاف الثالث فيمكنني القول انه
خلال الاقتحامين اللذين نتحدث عنهما
اقتحام نابلس في 22 واقتحام جنين في
السادس والعشرين من يناير
طبق الجيش فعليا ما يسمى بتقنيه طنجره
الضغط
حيث طوقوا اولا المنزل المستهدف الذي
يزعمون ان مقاتلي المقاومه الفلسطينيه
يحتمون فيه
ثم هاجموه بالصواريخ المضاده للبناء
مستخدمين بناء المنزل
كسلاح ضد مقاتلي المقاومه الفلسطينيه
المتواجدين داخله
[موسيقى]
الطريقه المستخدمه هي انه يتم تطويق
المنزل ودعوه الشخص للمغادره ويفترضون ان
الشخص لا يغادر بارادته الحره فيحاولون
اقناعه واحيانا يحضرون العائله لاقناعه
بالمغادره ويستخدمون الكلاب احيانا لدخول
المنزل
ويستمرون في تصعيد الاسلحه المستخدمه ضده
وصولا الى تفجير المنزل
كل مدينه فلسطينيه تقريبا بني لها نموذج
ثلاثي الابعاد وقبل ان يتوجه الجيش الى
هناك يتدربون على ما يشبه لعبه الكمبيوتر
يمكنهم التنقل والقياده عبر الشارع ورؤيه
المباني والشوارع التي سيواجهونها بالضبط
يمكنهم صعود الدرج هو دخول كل مبنى مهم
بالنسبه لهم
توجد ايضا وحده خاصه داخل وحده المستعربين
يسمونها راس المستعربين هؤلاء اشخاص
مختلفون لديهم القدره على ان يكونوا
جواسيس ولديهم موهبه التمثيل يمكنهم
الانتقال من شخصيه الى اخرى خلال خمس
ثواني
[موسيقى]
المساله هي ان خطه المستعربين وقائد
القوات السريه يجب ان تحصل على موافقه
رئيس الوزراء هل تفهم الان ما هو المستوى
الذي يتطلبه القضاء على ارهابي واحد اذا
لم يوافق رئيس الوزراء فلن تنفذ العمل
لا تقتصر الاضرار على جريمه القتل وتدمير
الممتلكات في المدن الفلسطينيه بل تمتد
لتطال نسيج المجتمع الفلسطيني انها تخلق
مستوى من الريبه يدمر ويمزق النسيج
الاجتماعيه في المدن الفلسطينيه
وجريمه الجنود المستعربين اضافه الى ما
يقومون به تتمثل في الارهاب الذي يبثونه
في كل ما تقع عليه عيناء
في الواقع العام الذي نعينه يوميا تقريبا
اسرائيل تقتل الفلسطينيين في جميع انحاء
الضفه الغربيه لكن بناء على البيانات التي
جمعناها خلال سنوات من العمل وفي الغالبيه
العظمى من الحالات لم نرى احدا يتعرض
للمساءله في الغالبيه العظمى من الحالات
يقرر الجيش في النتيجه اما عدم فتح تحقيق
او فتح تحقيق واغلاقه دون توجيه اتهام
لاحد
[موسيقى]
بموجب قانون الولايات المتحده هناك قانون
يحضر تقديم مساعده امنيه لدول اخرى
وتحديدا لوحدات قوات الامن التي تتوفر
معلومات موثوقه على ضلوعها في انتهاكات
صارخه لحقوق الانسان
ويجب ان يصدر توضيح من وزاره الخارجيه في
بعض هذه الحالات ان تلك الوحده التي شاركت
في المداهمه قد ارتكبت انتهاكا صارخا
لحقوق الانسان
حرب المدن التي تشنها اسرائيل عبر
المستعربين تواجه وعيا فلسطينيا باساليبهم
وتضع المستعرب في حاله خوف وترقب دائم ما
ادى الى اصابه العديد من منتسب وحده
المستعربين بامراض نفسيه وعقليه وصلت
ببعضهم الى الانتحار وفق ما كشف لنا
وصلت الى وضع بالغ الصعوبه اوشكت فيه
علاقات لنفسي فعلا هناك من اصدقائي من
قتلوا انفسهم احدهم ادخل المستشفى اثر
اصابته بالجنون كان يعاني حقا من اضطراب
ما بعد الصدمه سالته ذات يوم اذ زرته ما
خطبه قال لي لا اعرف من انا
رغم استراتيجيات عمليات وحده المستعربين
العسكريه والاستخباراتيه السريه لقمع
الفلسطينيين الا ان هذه العمليات باءت
بالفشل في احيان كثيره وتمكن الفلسطينيون
من ايجاد وسائلهم الخاصه لتخطي هذه
الاستراتيجيات التي لا تزال خارج المسائله
القانونيه ومحاسبه المجتمع الدولي رغم
توصيف بعضها كجرائم حرب
عناصر المستعربين شاركوا في العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي تصاعدت بشكل
شبه يومي في المدن الفلسطينيه منذ اوائل
العام الماضي واوضح تقرير لمؤسسه الحق
الفلسطينيه خاصه به برنامج للقصه بقيه بان
القوات الاسرائيليه مارست سياسه اطلاق
النار بهدف قتل مدنيين عزل خاصه في
محافظتي جنين ونابلس وقد استشهد ما لا يقل
عن
192 فلسطينيا من بينهم 44 طفلا خلال العام
الماضي منذ بدايه العام الحالي استشهد
اكثر من 110 فلسطينيين بينهم شهيدان في
هجوم وقع السبت الماضي في مخيم نور شمس
بطولكرم تناول تقرير مؤسسه الحق هي مقوات
الاحتلال في يناير الماضي بشن هجوم عسكري
على مخيم جنين على مقربه من موقع استشهاد
الزميل شيرين ابو عقله وصف الهجوم بانه
الاكثر دمويه منذ الانتفاضه الثانيه هذا
الهجوم اسفر عن استشهاد عشرت فلسطينيين
بينهم طفلان في الواقع واصابه نحو 20
اخرين استهدفت خلاله الممتلكات الخاصه
والبنيه التحتيه في المخيم واستخدمت منازل
مدنيين كنقات تستر ووفق شهود عيان وتقرير
طبي فان وسيم ابو جعص البالغ من العمر 16
عاما فقط استشهد بعدما مرت مركبه عسكريه
على جسده اثر اطلاق النار عليه وثقت مؤسسه
الحق استهداف احد المسعفين ومنع سيارات
الاسعاف من انقاذ المصابين بشكل متعمد
كجزء من استهداف قوات الاحتلال لمقدمه
المساعده الطبيه تكرر نفس الاسلوب في هجوم
بنابلس وذلك قبل ايام فقط استشهد فيه
ثلاثه فلسطينيين وفي هجوم الثاني والعشرين
من فبراير الماضي الذي اشرنا اليه في
قصتنا وقد اسفر عن استشهاد احد عشر
فلسطينيا احدهم هو عدنان بعاره ذو الاثنين
والسبعين عاما اطلق عليه قناص اسرائيلي
النار ثمان مرات وتم منع الطواقم الطبيه
من الوصول اليه قد اصيب اكثر من مئه
فلسطيني بينهم ثلاثه صحفيين وذلك خلال
تغطيتهم لهذا الهجوم هم احمد خلف محمد
الخطيب وعمير الستيه
[موسيقى]
طبعا ارحب بضيوفي الكرام معنا عمير
السيتيه الذي تحدثنا عنه وهو المصور
الصحفي من نابلس والذي تم استهدافه خلال
تغطيه
للاحداث في نابلس هناك والهجوم القوات
الاسرائيليه سنعود اليك عمير لنفصل اكثر
عن هذا الموضوع الذي تشبه قصتك فيه وقد
نجوت ولله الحمد بعد اصابتك مما تعرضت له
الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله في جنين للاسف
استشهدت على اثره معنى ايضا من غزه دكتور
سعيد بشارات الباحث في شؤون الاسرائيليه
ومن واشنطن الدكتور بروسفين الخبير
القانوني ونائب مساعد وزير العدل الامريكي
السابق نبدا معك عمير نرحب طبعا بضيوفنا
الكرام جميعا ونبدا معك عمير ان الحمد لله
على سلامتك انت نجوت من ذلك الهجوم الذي
تم
استهداف نابلس من خلاله وكون في تغطيه ذلك
مع زملاء اخرين لك شيرين
على اغتيالها عام حيث كانت تغطي هي بدورها
الهجوم الاسرائيليه على جنين
حينها لم تستبعد مصادر اسرائيليه من ان
جنديا في وحده دوف دوفان وهي من
المستعربين يكون المسؤول عن استهداف
الزميله شيرين ابو عقله في الفتره الاخيره
بدنا نسمع اكثر واكثر عن وحدات المستعربين
التي تندس بين المواطنين الفلسطينيين تسبق
هذه العمليات شرحنا ذلك بشكل مفصل في
فيلمنا الليله الذي خاصه به مؤسسه الحق
وفرنسك
يعني نتساءل حقيقه ما الذي رصدتموه
كصحفيين من تصاعد لوستيره استخدام هؤلاء
المستعربين في هذه العمليات عمير
يعطيك العافيه زميلتي فيروز
فعليا بدايه الروح سلاما نروح زميلتنا
شيرين ابو عاقله عليها رحمه الله
لمرور عام على استشهاد واستهدافها بدايه
بما انك خصصتي يوم 22/2 يلي هو 2023 فينا
نقول هو كان اكثر الايام دمويا في مدينه
نابلس
بهداك اليوم فعليا
بتذكر كل يعني كل لحظه هو ما مر عليه كتير
بس فعليا من الايام يلي تجسدت بالذاكره
بهديك اللحظه فعليا
تقريبا كان في الساعه العاشره وربع صباحا
طبعا كانت المنطقه المستهدفه هي منطقه
السوق الشرقي في مدينه نابلس طبعا هاي
المنطقه هي فعليا منطقه حيويه
تبعي الخضره والفواكه
وتكون هديك الوقت فعليا انزال البضائع
والمتجولين بكونوا من اهل المدينه فعليا
ورد مسج مباشره من احد الزملاء في ديك
المنطقه
عن وجود قوه خاصه تابعه للاحتلال وهي بزي
جيش الاحتلال علما انه كان قد سبقها
مستعربون فعليا مستعربون لم يتم كشفهم
فعليا تم كشف بعمليه فعليا لما لاحظوا
وجود قوات الاحتلال هديك اللحظه توجهت
بسرعه كبيره للمكان كنت على راس عملي طبعا
بالطريق فعليا كنا نلبس
لبس الصحافه الخاص مباشره
توجهت للمكان
يعني وصلت منطقه السوق الشرقي كنت فعليا
وصلت المكان مع وصول جيبات الاحتلال
بدا يعني بعد مرور من الوقت تقريبا كان في
هديك الوقت يعني جيبات الاحتلال توزعت
فعليا باب ومدخل كل زقه من زقاق هذيك
المنطقه فعليا يعني محكمه الاغلاق كما
ذكرت في التقرير يلي عفوا اللي تم اعداده
فعليا في ما يسمى عمليه طنجره الضغط فعليا
كان كل ذوق امام عجيب تابع
للجيشيه بالفعل باتت قوات الاحتلال
تستخدمها اكثر فاكثر في الضفه الغربيه
راينا ذلك كما ذكرت في نابلس لكن في جنين
ايضا تقارير تحدثت عن ذلك
ولاحظنا كما ذكرت بدايه تصاعد وتيره
استخدام المستعربين ماذا لو حدثتنا عن
مشاهداتك ربما بهذا الخصوص هل سبق لك وان
رصدت اقتراب المستعربين من تجمعات
الفلسطينيه كيفيه تحركهم تخفيهم راينا في
تقارير صحفيه ايضا انهم يتخفون وراينا ذلك
في فيلم الليله ايضا بازياء رجال دين
وسيدات محجبات ما الذي يمكن ان يقال بهذا
الخصوص
فعليا صحفيين من ناحيه
وصول المستعربين لاي مكان كان طبعا هاي
المعلومه بتكون فعليا صعبه الوصول لهيك
معلومه
ممكن انه انا يعني كعمير فعليا في احدى
المرات يلي على احد حواجز الاحتلال جنوب
مدينه نابلس كان يوميتها حاجز حواره كان
في تنجيك الوقت كان في مواجهات عنيفه كان
حرب على غزه توقع
يومها فعليا كنا في تصوير
بهديك المكان فوجئنا بوجود كمين من
مستعربين كانوا بين الشبان يومها تم القاء
القبض على عدد من الشبان فعليا هذيك
المنظر كان
وجه لوجه احنا
والمستعربين اذكر في مره اخرى كمان كانت
في
توقع
قبل عده سنوات
لم اذكر التاريخ جيدا كان في عمليه اقتحام
لمدينه نابلس
عند اذان المغرب كانت فعليا تواجد قوه
خاصه ايضا كانت بلباس جيش وليس مستعربين
توجد في منطقه الجبل الشمالي مدينه نابلس
كنت قريب من مكان فعليا وصلت
كان تواجدهم في المنطقه المستهدفه
مباشره
امرني بمغادرتي مكان فورا طلب بطاقه
الصحفيه
رغم هيفتم مصادرتها امرني بالرجوع فانا
برجع فعليا قوات احتيال قامت باطلاق النار
دخلت حتى اخد ساتر على احد المنازل في
هديك المنطقه فوجئت في داخل المنزل قوه
خاصه اخرى من جيش الاحتلال فعليا ولكن
كانوا على استعداد يبدو لي عمليه اعتقال
او اغتيال
يعني المؤشرات انه اسلم منها لا مدني لا
رجال لاطفال راينا طفلا وقد اتخذ درعا
بشريا في احدى العمليات ولا حتى الصحفيين
شيرين يعني كانت في تغطيه
احد العمليات العسكريه كما ذكرنا في جنين
وانت كنت في تغطيه نابلس كانت على اثر
اغتيالها يعني
ربما حمله تضامن واسعه عالميه مع موضوع
شيرين
وادانا ايضا لجنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نتساءل هل تغير الشيء في تعامل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والذاك مع الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين العاملين على الارض هل رضعها
ذلك ام ماذا ونحن نستشهد بقصتك التي حدثت
فبراير الماضي فقط انت وزملائك
يعني على مستوى مدينه نابلس لم يتغير شيء
صحيح مره عام ولكن الاحتلال يبقى احتلال
لا يميز في تلك العمليات اللي بكون فيها
تدخل عدد كبير من مستعربين والقوات الخاصه
والقوات الجيش احتلال وطائرات الدرون يعني
بتكون عمليه موسعه لا يميز بين احد يعني
في يوم 22 فبراير فعليا
يعني لحظه اصابته فعليا
اللي صار بعد مرور كان في وقت مر وانا
متواجد بالمكان حصل اشتباك فعليا بين
الشبان وقوات الاحتلال
يبدو ان احد جيبات احتلال حدد مصدر اطراق
النار اقترب من احد الزقاق يعني حاول انه
يدخل رغم انه ضيق احد الزقاق فعليا رد حصل
الاشتباك مره اخرى
بهذاك الوقت يعني قامت قوات اعتياب باطلاق
النار بشكل عشوائي كان بتذكر في امامي احد
الرجال كبار يعني كبير بالسن بنتقل من
المكان هو عزال ومبين انه كبير بالعمر
بنتقل من زاويه لاخرى تم اطلاق النار عليه
بشكل مباشر برجله
عمان وانتم في الميدان طبعا الحقيقه التي
ترصد كل شارده ووارد وتوثقها حتى يعني لا
يسقط هذا الحق بالتقادم ولا حتى مع الوقت
اشكرك جزيل الشكر عمير السيتي المصور
الصحفي الذي اصيب في هجوم نابلس في 22 من
فبراير الماضي كنت ضيفنا في برنامج القصه
بقيه اشكرك على شهادتك التي قدمتها اعود
الان لضيفي الكريمين
للدكتور سعيد بشارات يعني دكتور سعيد سمعت
لماذا ذكره عمير وشيرين ليست للاسف
الصحفيه الاولى ولا الاخيره التي تستهدفها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ويستمر ذلك كما
ذكر عمير كيف تفسر تكرار واستمرار عمليات
قتل الصحفيين في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله وتكرار محاولات اسرائيل التنصل من
مسؤولياتها
هي هذه الامور تعود الى السياسه الامنيه
التي
تنتهجها
دوله الاحتلال اسرائيل سواء ما يتعلق
بالصحفيين او حتى المسعفين او غيرهم في
خاصه في لحظه تنفيذ عمليات عسكريه خاصه او
كما يسمونها معقده وتحتاج الى وحده
الدفدفان ما حدث مع الشهيده شيرين ابو
عاقله رحمه الله ان هذه الوحده التي
قنصتها واستهدفتها لم تكن
العمليه التي قامت بها عبثيه لانها تقوم
بعمليه القنص بعد ان تكون قد تاكدت من
الهدف التي تريد ان تستهدفه الان لماذا
يتكرر هذا الفعل لان الامن عندهم حسب ما
يؤمنون فيه خاصه في الوحدات هاي الوحدات
النخبه وحدات الخاصه الامن يطغى على كل
شيء يطغى على الصحافه يطغى قيم الانسانيه
يطغى على القيم الصحيه وبالتالي
لا مانع عندهم من تنفيذ اغتيال او تحييد
تحييد مانع قد يمنعهم من الوصول الى الهدف
كتكتل صحفيين في المكان يمنعهم من تنفيذ
مهمه خاصه كما حدث في جنين يوم استشهاد
شيرين ابو عاقله او حتى كما يحدث في
عمليات اخرى
في مناطق عديده في الضفه الغربيه وحتى على
حدود قطاع غزه كون هذه الوحده كانت تعمل
هناك خاصه فيه لحظات الاشتباك مثل مسيرات
العوده في السقف في السابق وما بعدها
وبالتالي ما يحكم تصرف هذه الوحدات هو
الامن والامن مقدم عند هذه الوحدات كما
يتعلمون هم هم كما يتعلمون في منشور عام
الامن مقدم على اي شيء صحيح نعم دكتور
سعيد دعني اتحول للسيد بروسفين الخبير
القانوني نائب مساعد وزير العدل الامريكي
سابقا السيد يعني
هناك من يحمل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المسؤوليه في هذا الموضوع من افلات
اسرائيل من العقاب كيف ذلك ما يتحدث عن
تسريبات لتقرير للمنسق الامريكي لاسرائيل
والسلطه الفلسطينيه اشارت الى ان هذا
التقرير لم يتضمن شيئا وان الولايات
المتحده بوارد طي صفحه هذا الملف الى متى
التستر على جرائم اسرائيل وافلاتها من
العقاب
لا نعلم اذا كانت القضيه سيتم غلقها دون
ما اي تحرك قالت انه بدا عمليه تحقيق في
نوفمبر الماضي ليس لدينا اي تحديث بالنسبه
لي وضع التحقيقات التي تجري النمل ان
اسرائيل اكدت انه تم قتل الشيرين من قبل
قوات اسرائيليه ايا كانت الاشاره الغامضه
التي تمت الاشاره من خلالها على الرغم من
انه من المستحيل ان
تقوم الولايات المتحده
بملاحقه اي جهه
ضالعه في هذا الامر اذا سيكون هناك اعطاء
ولايه قضائيه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولدينا كذلك
اتفاقيه تسليم موجوده مع اسرائيل هناك
كذلك عقوبات اخرى بامكاننا ربما ان نفرضها
على سبيل المثال هناك لدينا قانون مجديسي
اذا ما تم تحديد شخص نعتقد انه تواطئ في
عمليه
شيرين ربما قد يتم منعه من الحصول على اي
معاملات تجاريه او الحصول على تاشيره
الدخول ومن الصحيح كذلك هناك كذلك محكمه
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه التي لديها
ولايه قضائيه عندما يتعلق الامر بالجرائم
جرائم الحرب عندما يكون هناك استهداف
متعمد بنسبه للمدنيين ونعلم ان شيرين كانت
تلبس لباس الصحفي وليس هناك اي خطا ربما
قد يتم الحديث عنه على انها كانت عدو او
ما الى ذلك هناك هذه الادوات التي تبقى
دائما متاحه لكن انت محقه عندما قلت
اخدمنا دلعتي بار قوه التاثير السياسي
لاسرائيل في الكونغرس ربما هي لا تميل الى
اخذ اي قرارات ضد اسرائيل في اي نطاق يذكر
على الرغم ان جانتان بولند هو دخل في
عمليه
تجسس وهو الان بالسجن
الوزراء في هذه الحاله
هنا لدينا ما يسمى بجريمه خيانه العهد او
التعامل بشكل غادر عندما يكون هناك شخص
يعمل بشكل وثيق مع الجيش
ويتخفى كمدنيه وبناء على عمليه التخفي فهو
يقوم بعمليه قتل والحاق الضرر بالعدو وهذه
جريمه تسمى خيانه العدل والخداع والتعامل
بشكل غادر وطبعا هذه التكتيكات تمت
الموافقه عليها من قبل
نتنياهو وبالتالي هو كذلك
يعتبر على انه يقوم
بالمشاركه في هذه العمليه من خلال القياده
التي يتقلدها
وسواء كان
النائب العام سياخذ اي قرارات بهذا الشان
ام لا لا نعلم اذا هناك انشغال بشكل قضايا
والجرائم التي تجري في اوكرانيا هناك كذلك
مبدا اخر يسمى مبدا التناسب عندما يكون
هناك شخص او عسكري يتخفى كما دليتنكر في
هيئه مدني ويقوم بخداع مجموعه سكانيه
مدنيه وكانه لا يشكل اي تهديد وربما قد
يدخل في عمليه اطلاق النار وحسب مبدا
التناسب عندما يكون هناك زياده مستوى
الضرر يتم تبريره فقط اذا كان الهدف
العسكري كبيرا وليس مبرر ان هذا الهدف
للاسف في اسرائيل في فلسطين عفوا بانه هدف
عسكري كبير حتى وان كان طفلا كما تابعنا
في عده شهادات تحول السيد او الدكتور سعيد
بشاره دكتور سعيد يعني لاحظنا كما ذكرنا
ارتفاع في وتيره استخدام هؤلاء المستعربين
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
في جنين ونابلس ماذا تقرا في ذلك وماذا
نعرفه اصلا عن هذه الوحدات ما تاريخ هذه
الوحدات والممنوع المعلومات المتوفره عن
تجنيدهم عملياتهم طريقه تحركهم كيفيه
تعامل الفلسطينيين معهم وهل هناك جهود
لمواجهتهم
اولا نبدا بالشكل الاول من السؤال لماذا
يستخدمونهم بهذه الكثافه خاصه في الايام
هاي في المدن الفلسطينيه في جنين في نابلس
هؤلاء مدربين تدريب معقد جدا على التخفي
على دخول داخل التجمعات السكانيه
الفلسطينيه ويهتمون بادق التفاصيل في
اثناء تنفيذ العمليه وبالتالي يسهل على
الجيش الدخول في الاماكن المقتظه كمخيم
جنين وحي الياسمين وبالتالي يخفف على
القوات المسانده عمليه الدخول وتنفيذ
عمليه الاغتيال هذا ما يتعلق بالشرق الاول
من سؤال ثانيا هذه الوحدات السريه وحدات
دوف دوفان وغيرها من الوحدات التابعه
للجيش والشرطه وحرس الحدود بدا تاريخها
منذ عام 1946 عندما شكل
الرئيس الخامس لدوله الاحتلال اول قسم
عربي في الهجانات والذي كانت مهمته تجنيد
المعلومات حول الفلسطينيين في فلسطين
وتجنيد العملاء حتى لصالح
العصابات الاسرائيليه في فلسطين ومن ثم
بعد ذلك بعد ان تم تشكيل دوله الكيان
اسرائيل تم تشكيل القسم القسم السري في
الشباك وهذا القسم السري قام بتجنيد
اليهود الذين ينحدرون من اصول عربيه في
صفوف الشباب من اجل التغلغل في القرى
الفلسطينيه من اجل السيطره على الحاله
النضاليه الفلسطينيه في ذلك الوقت حتى
انهم قاموا بارتكاب فضائع انسانيه من عن
طريق التزوج بمسلمات بدون علمهن بدون
علمهن وبعد ذلك كشف هذا في مجله اسرائيل
ديفينيس او اسرائيل وكشف هذا الموضوع
وصارت فضيحه كبيره عليه ومن ثم تم بعد ذلك
قبل الانتفاضه الاولى تشكيل
كوحده تابعه للجيش من اجل الانخراط في قمع
الانتفاضه الاولى وكانت هذه الوحدات تسهل
على الجيش الوصول الى المطلوبين الوصول
الى الاهداف في عمق السكان الفلسطينيين
وهذه الوحدات تتبع
للجيش والشرطه وحراس الحلول مثلا الجيش
يتبع له دفدوفان وشمشون شمشون تم حلها
عندما تم الخروج من قطاع غزه لانها كانت
مستلمه قطاع غزه ودمجها بعد ذلك في فرقه
الضفه الغربيه وحرس الحدود يتبع له يماس
الضفه الغربيه وينماس القدس ويماس غزه وتم
ايضا حل هذه الوحده
وهناك الشرطه يطبع لها اليمام وتدعو نيم
وكل هذه الوحدات الخاصه تقوم بعمليات
الدخول وتنفيذ المهمات الخاصه والمعقده في
داخل التجمعات السكانيه الفلسطينيه ويتم
انتقائهم بحرفيه كامله بحيث لو جاءهم 700
مجند يتم اختيار فقط ثلاثه من المحترفين
جدا القادرين على حفظ السر القادرين على
التمول في وسط سكان
العربين السابقين ذكر بانهم عرضه لامراض
نفسيه قد تؤدي الى الاتحاد كون الضغط
النفسي عليهم لانهم لا يعرفون من من من
يصبحون السؤال الليله حقيقه ما امكانيات
ملاحقه هؤلاء دوليا خاصه ان هذه العمليات
كما تابعنا في الشهاده لا تتم الا بغطاء
رسمي كبير من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
لا اعتقد انه يمكن متابعتهم لانهم اصلا
غير معروفين وحتى قائد غير معروف مرموز له
بالحرف دال لا يوجد شخصيه لهم عباره عن
اشباح لا احد يراهم لا احد يعرفهم احيانا
يتم ضبطهم في صور مقاطع الفيديو التي تصور
في مكان العمليه لكن في الغالب غير
معروفين وهم يتبعوا للجيش والجيش هو من
كلفهم وهناك لو حدث مثلا تعقيب في عمليه
وقتل احد الصحفيين كما حدث مع شيرين ابو
عاقله يتم تشكيل لجنه داخل الجيش تقوم هذه
اللجنه بالتحقيق وبالتالي تحرم مؤسسات
قانونيه دوليه والمحكمه
الدوليه من التحقيق وبالتالي هذه الامور
لحد الان لا يوجد
على سؤالي التالي المتعلق اذا ان كان من
الصعب كشف هؤلاء وان كانت اسرائيل تتكتم
وتتستر عليهم بشكل كبير لحمايتهم من
مسؤوليه القانونيه الواقعه على الدول التي
تدعم جهاز امني وعسكري يقوم بمثل هذه
العمليات تحديدا نتحدث عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهي الداعم الاكبر
لاسرائيل
هناك كما اشرت هناك مسؤوليه القياده
والسيطره حتى لو لم تكن قادره على تحديد
الشخص الذي قام بارتكاب هذه الجرائم
بطريقه متخفيه عمليه القتل هم يعملون
وبشكل وثيق الصله مع القوات الاسرائيليه
وذلك من اجل قتل الفلسطينيين هذه
المسؤوليه مسؤوليه القياده التي تكمن في
يد رئيس الوزراء وما قد تكشف عن ذلك الشخص
حتى تكون هناك ملاحقه ممكنه من خلال محكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه القانون والنظام الاساسي
ويقول بشكل واضح لانك رئيس دوله فانت لا
تتمتع
بالحصانه من اجل التي تمنعك من الملاحقه
اسرائيل هي اكثر قوه مما كانت عليه في
1948 عندما ولدت ولست ادري اذا كانت
الولايات المتح بخصوصا حتى لو كان الرئيس
جو بايدن ربما بعيد عن نتنياهو
لكن اخدم اعتبار تاثير اسرائيل في كونغرس
وسواء كان لبيض القوه
ليفرض على اسرائيل تقلب المسؤوليه ارتفع
على شيئا او ربما التعويض بالنسبه لمن
قتلوا ودويهم او ما الى ذلك هذه من الامور
التي ربما من الممكن ان تحدث بناء على
دوره انتخابات القادمه لكن على المدى
القصير لا ارى ذلك متحققا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر لكن حتما العداله مثل ما ذكرنا لا
تسقط بالتقادم ولعلها تجد طريقها في يوم
من الايام اشكر جزيل الشكر الخبير
القانوني دكتور بروسفين نائب مساعد وزير
العدل الامريكيه السابق ضيفنا من واشنطن
كما اشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من غزه دكتور
سعيد بشارات الباحث في شؤون الاسرائيليه
ونشكر عمير الزميل عمير الذي كان
معنا في بدايه هذه الحلقه من نابلس ختام
هذه الحلقه من برنامج القصه البقيه نعود
ونلقاكم باذن الله مع بقيه لقصه جديده
دمتم في رعايه الله والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله تعالى وبركاته
[موسيقى]